MARTIN OMANDER: Hi.
Welcome to Root Access, the show
on Google Developers Live
about startups.
My name is Martin Omander, and
I'm joined here today by Don
Dodge, Googler, long-time
investor, and startup
evangelist.
We're going to have a series of
discussions about new hot
technologies.
And today we're going to talk
about indoor location.
Don, you've invested in indoor
location startups.
There have been some recent
acquisitions.
What's this indoor location
all about?
What are the use cases?
DON DODGE: Yeah, so indoor
location has gotten a lot of
attention recently, because
there have been three
high-profile acquisitions
in this space.
Apple acquired WiFiSLAM.
Ruckus networks acquired one,
and there was a third one that
was acquired.
So it's getting a lot of
attention from investors and
technologists about, hey,
what's going on here?
What's going on is, because of
the emergence of smartphones,
everyone has a computer in their
pocket that's capable of
displaying a map, and it has a
built-in GPS, and a built-in
Wi-Fi, and a built-in
Bluetooth.
Those technologies can be used
to locate you indoors.
So GPS and Maps work
great outdoors.
But we spend 90% of
our time indoors.
So inside an office building,
inside a shopping mall, inside
a college dorm or wherever,
GPS doesn't work, so Maps
don't help.
And these indoor location
technologies do work indoors
and open up all sorts
of opportunities.
So that's why it's a hot
trend right now.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah, right.
So that's why we're seeing it
now and not five years ago?
Because we all have
smartphones?
DON DODGE: Right.
The technology has been
around for a while.
But the ability to use it
really depends on the
smartphone and the built-in
sensors in the smartphone, the
Wi-Fi radios and Bluetooth
and GPS.
All of those things together
make it possible to be able to
do indoor location with
technologies that have been
around for a while.
MARTIN OMANDER: So I know
what building I'm in.
I entered by the front
door here today.
How can knowing exactly where
in the building I am help me
or others around me?
DON DODGE: Well, first,
how would it work?
So there would be a little
sensor on the front
door when you enter.
So that's what's known
as a truth point.
From that truth point, you can
use a variety of technologies
to determine where you
are in the building.
So it could use the
accelerometer, or the gyro, or
the compass, or other sensors
that are built into your phone
to count the steps and direction
from that known
truth point.
Or when you enter the building,
it has Wi-Fi, so
your smartphone picks up the
Wi-Fi signals and can
triangulate from those signals
where you are in the building.
Or it could use Bluetooth,
low-energy type beacons that
are on the wall or in
the ceiling to help
navigate where you are.
Another approach is something
called ByteLight.
It uses LED lights that pulse.
And the pulses in those lights
are so fast the human eye
can't see them, but when you're
holding your smartphone
in your hand, there's a
front-facing camera.
That camera picks up the pulses
and can identify which
light is emitting that pulse
and, therefore, triangulate
where you are.
So that's a quick overview of
some of the technologies that
are used and how they work.
But now that you know
how they work, how
would a user use them?
Or what applications of this
technology are there?
Well, the obvious ones are
things like retailers and
supermarkets and that
sort of thing.
Let's say you have a shopping
list for the grocery store,
and it has 30 items on it.
If you're like me, you've gone
through the store, and you get
27 of the 30 items, and then you
have to backtrack to find
the last three, like
where are they?
You somehow missed them.
MARTIN OMANDER: Oh, yes.
Been there, done that, yes.
DON DODGE: So you could use this
to put your shopping list
in your phone, and then the
phone would create a map for
you and tell you exactly
where each of those
products are on the shelf.
Or if you're in a retail
location like Walmart or
Lowe's or Walgreens where they
have thousands of SKUs, you
could do a search for "tell me
where the Gucci bags are," or
"tell me where the spaghetti
is," and it will take you
right to that point.
So you could use them
in those ways.
Social applications.
You want to know where
your friends are.
You're at a concert
or you're at a
conference with 5,000 people.
And you know you have
10 friends there,
but where are they?
You can't find them.
Well, with indoor location, you
can type in the name of
that friend.
They accept that they want you
to be able to know where they
are, and then, boom, on
the map it shows you
exactly where they are.
Or if you take your family to
the shopping mall, and your
kids are running off in other
directions, and you go this
way, and the spouse goes the
other way, on a map you can
actually see where you are.
So there are all kinds of
different applications of the
technology and many more that
we haven't thought of that
will come up in the future.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
Because it's still early
days, it sounds like.
DON DODGE: Very early days.
This is why it's a hot topic and
a hot trend, because it's
a technology that's enabling
all kinds of applications.
And just like GPS or Maps, I
remember when they were first
introduced 15 years ago.
No one really understood
how they would be used.
And now, they're ubiquitous.
They're in all kinds
of applications.
MARTIN OMANDER: And we can't
live without them.
DON DODGE: Exactly.
The same is going to happen
with indoor location.
There are a few businesses and
use cases that we can clearly
understand, but there will be
hundreds more that will evolve
that we just haven't
thought of.
MARTIN OMANDER: Right.
So you mentioned there were
a number of different
technologies here at play.
Will one of them become the
standard in a couple of years?
DON DODGE: Perhaps, but I don't
think so, because there
are a variety of different ways
to approach the problem.
So Wi-Fi is one place,
Bluetooth, lights in the
ceiling, sound sensors,
beacons.
There are all these different
technical approaches.
They each have their advantages
and disadvantages,
and they sort of depend on cost
of infrastructure versus
low cost or accuracy.
So if you want to be accurate
to within one foot or one
meter, those technologies are
going to cost a little less
than technologies that
can do it within 3
meters or 10 meters.
So there's a cost versus
accuracy thing.
There's also an open and
ubiquitous versus private and
proprietary.
So some applications don't
care about being open and
ubiquitous.
They're very specific
applications for a retail
store or for a venue
or whatever.
And there are others that care
more about being open.
So it depends.
The short answer is no, I don't
think that there will be
one or two leaders.
I think there will be probably
20 different companies who
will be successful
in this area.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow.
It will be interesting to see
how that shakes out over the
next couple of years.
DON DODGE: That's why it's a hot
trend and a topic we need
to talk about.
MARTIN OMANDER: Hot trend and a
topic we need to talk about.
Good.
Thanks, Don.
That's all for today.
Thank you for joining us.
If you have any questions you'd
like us to bring up in
future episodes, please leave
them in the YouTube comments.
Thank you for joining
us, and see you next
week at the same time.
Bye.